Guys, it can be hard
to say goodbye,
but sometimes you have to,
and there are a few things
I'd like to say goodbye to
right now.
It's time for "Go On, Git."
-♪ Go on, git ♪
♪ Go on, git ♪
♪ Go on, go on, go on, git ♪
[ Western electric guitar
twanging ]
♪♪
-Go on, git, Super Bowl ads
that keep airin'
after the Super Bowl.
You're like the weird
20-year-old
who still hangs out
at his old high school.
It's over, hoss!
Seein' you try
to relive your glory
during a rerun of "NCIS"
just makes me S-A-D.
Now learn something from
those Budweiser frogs and...
[Croaking] Go. On. Git.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Go on, git!
Keys.
It's 2021.
Why am I still walking around
with a bunch of tiny
jagged knifes in my pocket?
Make me sound like sleigh bells.
Even Motel 6 upgraded
to the key card,
and they can't even afford
water pressure!
[ Laughter ]
So, keys, uh, go on...
use yourselves
to unlock the door, then git.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Go on, git.
Seeds.
[ Laughter ]
I see you tryin'
to act like a food,
sneakin' your way into salads
and smoothies and whatnot.
But y'all ain't food!
You go into the ground
and become food!
You are pre-food!
So go on, git,
back into the ground, seeds,
and come back when you're an
actual full-grown sunflower.
And then I'll eatcha!
Then I'll eatcha!
[ Laughter ]
[ Spitting, can dinging ]
Sunflower, I'll eat you!
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
Go on, git...
...TV shows where sound effects
are way louder
than the talkin' parts.
When I'm immersin' myself
into a make-believe world
of double-crossing CIA agents,
I want to relax, not play a game
of volume chess
with my TV remote.
So GO ON, git, BACK to
ONE CONSISTENT VOLUME!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Go on, git, thesauruses.
You are unnecessary,
superfluous,
heck, even redundant.
But, hey, since you like
pretty words so much,
I got a couple for ya.
Abdicate your position.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Go on, git! Crab cakes.
When I hear the word "cake," I
think of a sweet, spongy treat.
But when I hear the word "crab,"
I think of the ocean's
scariest STD.
And that's a no-go
for my appetito.
So go on, git, crab cakes,
and come back when you're
tiny cakes for crabs
'cause that'd be adorable.
Well, it's hard to see 'em go,
but I'm glad I got that
out of my system.
We'll be right back with
Dwayne Johnson, everybody.
[ Spits, can dings ]
♪♪